NASH ISLAM: At G&R, we're
rebuilding modernization
solutions for local content
in the Bangla language.
We work the websites and apps
to publish ads on their Bangla
content, and we work
with advertisers
that want to
communicate in Bangla.
MUHAMMAD NAZIMUDDAULA: G&R
used to provide services
for our clients, like website
development, Facebook app
development.
But later we found
that it's actually
defocusing us from
our main goal.
So we stopped doing
that and started
focusing on our product.
NASH ISLAM: On the
developer side of things,
we use various APIs--
Charts API, Maps API.
We even use a Spreadsheets API.
We also have built up a lot
of custom Chrome extensions
for our internal
client service needs.
What's next for G&R
is a lot of growth.
We want to focus
definitely on incentivizing
more local content in
the Bangla language,
but also in other
languages around the world,
such as Burmese or
Persian or Nepalese
to help those people
bridge the digital divide.
We also want to be more
of a big data company.
As we're upgrading
our infrastructure,
we see more room to help bring
other businesses in Bangladesh
onto that same stack.